immerhin weiß ich jetzt schon dass man
eine bestrafung nicht mittel ausfallen
wird ich habe mich selber angefasst ohne
erlaubnis alles glatt der nimmer ein
gesicht jetzt herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute machen wir wie
es der titel schon gesehen hat eine fan
fiction lesen und dabei wasser im mund
behalten challenge wie man es heute auch
ein glas wasser mir wurde vorgeschlagen
mal eine mine lupin fiction zu lesen ich
dachte mir kommt mir das doch mit einem
frischen glas wasser mit dabei andreas
geht und wir machen heute eine kleine
sexy fertigten challenge keine andere
hat einmal location ausgesucht die heißt
es am anfang ein fan fiction stars meine
warnung dieses buch enthält sexuelle
szenen und bdsm wer das nicht mag oder
zu jung dafür ist solche bitte nicht
weiterlesen
ich muss noch sagen bevor es losgeht das
heutige video wird wirklich bisschen
heftiger wenn ihr generell mit solchen
bisschen abwägen perversen sachen oder
so nichts anfangen könnt nichts davon
wissen wollt scheidet einfach ab das
wird echt extrem hatte klar soweit klar
so eine sache noch zu entwickeln ich
finde es im allgemeinen wieder cool und
ich fühle mich damit auch gar nicht
lustig mache aber die sache ist einfach
glaube ich richtig extrem nach bewusst
extrem geschrieben deswegen sowohl profi
luca verschwitzt wurde ich war und
versuchte mein atem zumindest wenig
unter kontrolle zu kriegen hatte schon
wieder einen verdammt heißen trauen
vermeiden beiden teams gehabt
bei den blick nehmen mich sah ich das
noch max neben mir lag cassis sebastian
schon los war in dem ruhigsten im jungen
neben mir meerblick die latte die ich
durch meinen traum hatte ich meine
maxime schicht immer tief und fest also
könnte ich doch theoretisch schule das
erst mitbekommen würde
noch bevor ich meinen gedanken richtig
zu ende führen konnte legte ich bei mir
selbst hand an und fing dann gesamt mich
zu massieren leise und zwar wirklich
leise bedacht darauf im netten nichts
wecken löst sich das problem was mein
traum gezaubert hatte meine hand wurde
immer schneller an als ich kurz davor
waren wurde ich von einem flug
unterbrochen
fakt ist doch nicht wahr sein was sind
überhaupt downside ja gesagt hat ich bin
wirklich dankbar wirklich dankbar dafür
dass ich jetzt in diesem ersten teil der
geschichte erst mal raus bin sieh mich
an braucht denn sofort wichtig mich um
und seinen braunen augen mit dem ich
sauer an starten was hast du getan luca
zischte er zwischen zusammengebissenen
zähnen und ich wusste ich war ziemlich
überrascht immerhin hat sich einer
meiner hauptwegen gebrochen immerhin
weiß ich jetzt schon dass meine
bestrafung nicht mehr ausfallen wird ich
habe mich selber angefasst oder erlaubt
ist
[Musik]
das kommentiert oder das ist vollkommen
abgefasst ist luca gönnt sich und er
dachte nicht an luca ist der sklave von
max und dir deswegen die beiden domina
sticker filmischen das nicht selber
anfassen nur mit der erlaubnis sagte
dass er mich selber angefasst so
kleinert von mir immer noch stark und
ich wünsche mir nichts mehr als dass ich
kommen durfte
ausziehen auf dem boden und auf youtube
sofort der baute er sein mentor und ich
tat sofort was ihm über wohl mein blick
war gesenkt auf dem boden mehr als fünf
minuten saß ich an die gott mich schufen
knie wie ein hund und gesenkten blicken
rollins band weil ich endlich schritte
hinter mir ausmachen könnte doch was als
nächstes kam lieblich absolut richtig
bemerkte erst was geschah als das
schloss auch schon zu kriegen war wenn
sich der kleine mitteilen käfig um mein
bestes stück geschlossen hat war alles
gleich kann sogar die person ist
geschrieben hätte wie gesagt ich finde
es absolut cool auch bisschen extrem
oder geschichte zu schreiben möchte von
allen guten geistern verlassen im käfig
um sein bestes bitte was ist das für ein
hotel verbringen das aus der perspektive
von lukas geschehen musste luca dabei
vorstellen wahrscheinlich sie dieses
video findest du hier siehst viel spaß
dass hier wirklich keinen spaß werden
du weißt dass du bestraft werden muss
richtig doch im nächsten moment reißt
seine hände weg nicht verspürte ein
brennen auf meinen hintern klasse des
leh aber trotzdem genoss ich ist denn
leider habe ich war max und sebastian
festgestellt dass ich etwas
masochistisch veranlagt bin und ich
ziemlich gefallen und die schmerzen
[Musik]
diese personen den richtigen heiß weil
anleger irgendwas muss ich tätig
losschickt du bist masochistisch
veranlagt es macht nicht metall fertig
müsste abbrechen das ist das ist heute
für den mund so mégane schränkt nenne
ich möchte etwas dazu sagen ich möchte
mich dafür entschuldigen dass solche
geschichten meinen videos vorgelesen
werden aber es fällt schwer weil dort so
wächst immer öfter ist ein stück was hat
schon spürte ich den nächsten schlag der
durch die schmale gärten einem kabbala 2
danke
bis heute ist nicht alle anderen eltern
nach acht weiteren schlägen wird
eigentlich wieder letztes mit einem
folie angewiesen wurde mich mit dem po
in die luft gestreckt aufs bett jetzt
geht's ab leute sofort kann man diesen
befehl nach und spürte auch schon kurze
zeit später wie max mit anlagen oder
die jungs hatten davon jetzt diese
geschichte gerade vorlese die hassen
mich wirklich dafür alles klar
kurz ständig auf als ich max aus mit
sekunden später umkamen
immer wieder kamen die leisen laut der
lust über meine lippen kurz darauf dass
ich auch schon wird zog sich langsam aus
ich hoffe dass bei der familie sieht
dieses video also leute jetzt schon 15
16 minuten pro aufnahme und ich muss
sagen es ist wirklich es ist nummer ja
ich weiß nicht wie er damit umgeht ich
weiß nicht wie ich damit umgehen werden
leute deswegen belastungs erstmal dabei
welt das ganze gefallen hat ich habe ich
gern den kommentare und zeigt somit nur
falls das nicht gefallen da könnte es
auch die kommentare schreiben
ist doch mein experiment leute wirklich
die gefahr aus dem daumen nach oben
daumen zeigt das ist hier oben könnte
man kann abonnieren und hier unten altes
video abchecken die zufällig als die
alles klar